disco delivers affordable science-backed
skin care treatments to your home the
disco starter set helps guys fight oily
skin and razor burn and keeps your skin
hydrated i've had great results with it
you'll get 30 off at letsdisco.com
pacman the link is down below
so yesterday as many of you
listened to and watched and emailed me
about i interviewed donald trump's
former attorney michael cohen now
michael cohen disagrees with me or at
least you know i could be swayed but
i've been saying i don't believe donald
trump is ultimately going to be charged
with any crimes michael cohen believes
that he will
but michael's commentary was really
restricted
to the financial stuff that michael
cohen would know about meaning sometimes
overstating and sometimes understating
the value of different assets for the
purposes of either obtaining loans or
minimizing taxes or whatever the case
may be
there is now
another layer as to the possible
criminal charges that maybe would be
coming donald trump's way now i still am
very skeptical that this is going to
become a real thing but at this point
there's a member of congress that is
alluding to it you know so so i do think
that it's real enough that we should be
talking about it what am i talking about
here
well yesterday we played
uh uh we we rather we reviewed text
messages
that republican congresswoman liz cheney
read
during a hearing
which came from various fox news hosts
and donald trump jr to donald trump's
former chief of staff mark meadows now
we're gonna now look at some video of
her talking about this and it's about a
three minute video i'm going to play it
all so that you get the full context pay
special attention near the end where
cheney actually says
did donald trump through action or
inaction
corruptly seek to obstruct or impede
congress's proceedings i'll tell you in
a moment why that is so relevant let's
take a look at the video
these text messages leave no doubt
the white house knew exactly what was
happening here at the
capitol members of congress the press
and others wrote to mark meadows as the
attack was underway
one text mr meadows received said quote
we are under siege here at the capitol
another
quote they have breached the capital
in a third
mark
protesters are literally storming the
capital
breaking windows on doors
rushing in
is trump going to say something
a fourth
there's an armed standoff at the house
chamber door
and another from someone inside the
capitol
we are all helpless
dozens of texts including from trump
administration officials
urged immediate action by the president
quote
potus has to come out firmly and tell
the protesters to dissipate
someone is going to get killed
in another mark he needs to stop this
now
a third in all caps
tell them to go
home
a fourth
and i quote
potus needs to calm this [ __ ] down
indeed
according to the records multiple fox
news hosts
knew the president needed to act
immediately
they texted mr meadows
and he has turned over those texts
quote mark
the president needs to tell people in
the capitol to go home
this is hurting all of us he is
destroying his legacy
laura ingram wrote
please get him on tv
destroying everything you have
accomplished
brian kilmeade texted
quote can he make a statement
ask people to leave the capitol
sean hannity urged
as the violence continued
one of the president's sons
texted mr meadows quote
he's got to condemn this [ __ ] asap
the capitol police tweet is not enough
donald trump jr texted
meadows responded
quote i'm pushing it hard i agree
still
president trump did not immediately act
donald trump jr texted
again
and again
urging action by the president
quote
we need an oval office address
he has to lead now
it has gone too far
and gotten out of hand end quote
but hours passed
without necessary action by the
president
these non-privileged texts are further
evidence
of president trump's supreme
dereliction of duty
during those 187 minutes
and mr meadows testimony will bear on
another key question before this
committee
did donald trump
through action or inaction
corruptly seek to obstruct or impede
congress's official proceedings to count
electoral votes
mark meadows testimony is necessary to
inform our legislative judgments okay so
that's a lot of different things that
she said
but at the end she says did donald trump
corruptly seek to obstruct or impede
congress's proceedings
this is being considered
the most direct signal thus far
that there is the
possibility
that donald trump might be charged with
pretty serious federal crimes what
cheney read there relates to 18 u.s code
subsection 1505 obstruction of
proceedings before departments
agencies and committees the issue here
of course being donald trump's attempt
to obstruct
investigation
into himself
and also
attempts to obstruct the proceedings
which would correctly
assess joe biden the winner of the 2020
election and it reads whoever with
intent to avoid evade prevent or
obstruct compliance
with any civil investigative demand duly
improperly made
willfully withholds misrepresents
removes from any place conceals covers
up etc etc shall be fined under this
title imprisoned not more than five
years or if it involves international or
domestic terrorism up to eight years so
the idea here is that liz cheney is
hinting at possible criminal charges for
donald trump
over
the entire situation now that has
exploded for donald trump's former chief
of staff mark meadows involving text
messages involving a powerpoint which
very directly said here's how we would
do the coup and hear the different
elements that we would look at doing
there
a number of different legal analysts are
talking about this harvard law school
professor emeritus lawrence tribe
pointed out that refers specifically to
u.s code subsection 1505 18 us code
subsection 1505
and um cnn's ellie honig made a similar
comment when he was interviewed by john
berman and so this is now
going to be a question of whether or not
donald trump
could get away
with claiming presidential immunity that
would be the next layer here imagine
that this happens okay and again
this is why i see it as unlikely
but i'm a little bit closer to thinking
it's conceivable that there could be
charges although i the guy is not going
to spend the day in prison
if indeed they tried to charge trump for
his role
in any of these various obstructive acts
because there's actually no shortage of
them
he would
likely first claim that he had
presidential immunity for anything that
he did
now
the problem with that
is how do you justify trump's
obstructive actions with regard to
investigations into him or directions of
others to obstruct how do you justify
that as a presidential duty because at
the end of the day
immunity
is limited based on the legal experts
i've spoken to in the scholarship that
i've read
the immunity is limited to his official
duties or things carried out clearly in
his role as president so
fortunately or unfortunately i know many
of you don't like this but when a
president makes a decision for a country
to go to war
and people die as a result of that could
be american troops could be foreign
troops could be civilians
it is very difficult to hold them
accountable
uh as if these were individual criminal
acts because they do have pretty broad
presidential immunity
could it be challenged maybe but the
point here is
we are now arguably outside of that the
argument that would be made against
trump's claim of presidential immunity
and there's a bunch of different people
who have tweeted about this and written
good commentaries how do you justify
that donald trump's obstructive acts
related to his own wrongdoing
would be covered by presidential
immunity and there are some people who
say yeah if the president does it it's
not a crime uh
hearkening back uh to to richard nixon
but there is a debate about that and
fundamentally if there were charges
donald trump would likely try to assert
that he had presidential and has
presidential immunity on the basis of
what he did and then it would become
well are the obstructive acts actually
uh
uh covered by immunity and there is an
argument to be made that they are not it
would be a fight it would be a very very
big legal fight could be ages but the
first signal that maybe there are people
in congress a republican no less
thinking of crimes related to donald
trump's actions of course the crimes
would be up to the justice department to
bring it
still doesn't seem that merrick garland
seems super interested in that that'll
be a story for a different day
there is something really interesting
going on with now senate minority leader
mitch mcconnell the republican senator
from kentucky one republican senator
from kentucky now i want to be really
clear
mitch mcconnell is still a disgusting
republican
he maneuvered to keep barack obama's
supreme court pick out of the supreme
court and rush in donald trump's pick
specifically thinking about amy coney
barrett his morals his political views
they are vile in every way and that that
doesn't change but
as a curiosity
mitch mcconnell appears to have sort of
had enough of the extreme pro-trump wing
of the party trashing him and he might
be ready to throw trumpists into the
proverbial trash i'm going to play a
clip for you here in which mitch
mcconnell was asked during a press
conference
did you
speak to mark meadows on january 6th as
we learn about all of the different
people that did
and what is your thought about all of it
and the involvement of these fox news
hosts with meadows and the
administration and mitch says i didn't
speak to mark meadows but i am
interested to see all of the
participants who were involved revealed
and i'm getting the sense that he's
ready to let him hang so check out the
clip uh here's mitch mcconnell learning
from the house select committee that a
number of republicans have reached out
to mark meadows asking for donald trump
to get more involved and do more on
january 6 to secure this building were
you personally in contact with mark
meadows that day and other white house
officials to urge the trump to do more
yeah i was not but i do think we're all
watching as you are
what is unfolding on the house side
and it
will be interesting to reveal all the
participants who were involved
[Music]
mitch mcconnell and other establishment
republicans
have been targeted by personal attacks
and name-calling and hostility
by trump and trumpists for a year now
i think that mitch is sick of it i think
it has had a major impact on him look at
all of the people that donald trump has
endorsed so far for 2022
many of them have said i would not
support mitch mcconnell being the leader
of republicans in the senate trump has
said mitch mcconnell should leave the
position
trump has said mitch mcconnell is bad
now you know to use very simplistic
language and to be fair mitch mcconnell
is also closing in on retirement
there is no defense of mitch mcconnell
or of establishment republicans but this
is a recognition
that mitch really may have no interest
at all
in running interference for the people
that might be brought down by the
january 6th committee and that includes
other republicans from the more
sycophantic pro-trump wing of the
republican party now if we zoom out
i don't expect this to change the
republican party in any substantive way
but i do hope that it will be another
element of this building republican
civil war pro-trump versus anti-trump
which if we're lucky will interfere with
republicans being able to run solid
campaigns and hopefully i mean if the
left can get it together will allow for
some victories by
democrats and others on the left
that's my interest in this i'm being
very upfront with you that that's my
horse in the race so to speak and at the
end
there's no real moral stance here for
mitch mcconnell it's just what's in it
for him it's bad for him if there are
more republicans in the house and senate
that don't like him it's bad for him
if republicans who won't support his
leadership get elected to the senate he
doesn't like being called names he might
want revenge that's all it is there's no
big moral awakening here for mitch
mcconnell it's just if it's bad for him
he'll be against it and it seems pretty
clear at this point that the trumpiest
wing of the republican party
isn't particularly big on mitch
mcconnell so it's going to be
fascinating to watch i continue to
believe that the left should inflame
this republican civil war
as much as the left can it can only be
good for the left it might not do that
much good
but it's not going to be bad it and it
might be good and so it's worth doing
all right two announcements today number
one
yesterday's town hall had to be
rescheduled uh a combination of tech
issues and youtube live
being in and out right when the town
hall was scheduled means we have
rescheduled it for two weeks from
yesterday the new town hall date is
december 28th 6 pm eastern
that will really be the last one of the
year because it's like three days from
the end of the year so december 28 6 p.m
eastern that's the new date secondly
we are planning on the biggest ever one
day membership bomb
on january 1st 2022
we will notify everybody on our mailing
list of an ungodly membership discount
on january 1st
get on my mailing list at
davidpakman.com
to be notified
on that very very special day which will
sort of be the unofficial kickoff of the
midterm election so just sign up for the
mailing list at davidpakman.com we'll
take a quick break and it is quite a
program we have for you today
one of our sponsors is disco there are
so many different types of bogus skin
care products for men out there what you
really want to go with is just something
affordable effective and created by
dermatologists that's why we have disco
which delivers the science-backed
over-the-counter skin treatments that
dermatologists recommend to their
patients every day
the disco starter set is a simple way to
take care of your skin in three quick
steps the face cleanser stick fights
oily skin the exfoliating face scrub
prevents razor burn and the face
moisturizer keeps your skin hydrated
disco can also help with ingrown hairs
dry skin acne and other things you just
need 60 seconds a day i've been using it
for a while now i'm seeing a noticeable
difference maybe you can even tell
check out disco try out the products for
yourself you will like the results and
you'll get thirty percent off when you
go to
letsdisco.com
or just enter the code pacman the link
is down below we're continuing to follow
the impact of different vaccine
requirements and some of the most
interesting ones to look at are actually
the ones for the military we learned
from defense secretary lloyd austin that
the military would be indeed
implementing an actual vaccine mandate
it's just you've just got to get
vaccinated that's it it's not a protocol
where you can test out you got to be
vaccinated and we are now starting to
see the first discharges from the
military for vaccine refusal now the
right is making a big deal out of this
and framing it as unpatriotic joe biden
by making service members get vaccinated
and losing service members refusing to
get vaccinated is weakening the military
and is therefore unpatriotic and a
socialist and a marxist and a communist
and you know right like follow it along
to this whole thing
27 people have been discharged ladies
and gentlemen that is that is that what
we know so far uh the air force has
discharged 27 service members for
refusing the covet vaccine these are the
first service members to be
involuntarily discharged for refusing
the vaccine spokesperson for the air
force said they received counseling
about the vaccines
they still refused
and commanders made the decision to
discharge them for refusing to comply
with that requirement
uh considered to be a lawful or order
all 27 of these individuals were with
the air force under six years
there may have been additional reasons
for the discharge but the covid vaccine
refusal was at least one of those
reasons now they announced this back in
august so they had august september
october november we are now in december
the air force had a deadline of november
2nd which was one of the earlier
deadlines and of course you don't
immediately remove the people on
november 2nd you've got to go through a
process and that has now taken place
each branch of the military has its own
process for discharge and they all
include we're going to counsel you about
the vaccine we're going to educate you
about the vaccine
then there will be disciplinary action
you will still have an opportunity to
get vaccinated and only after that will
we start with the discharges and what is
fascinating about it is that what the
right says is a horribly authoritarian
thing is number one something that has
been in the military for what what a
hundred years i mean i don't even know
when the first military vaccine
requirement came in but in particular
in the military
there have been so many vaccine
requirements that nobody questioned for
so long so number one if this is
authoritarian
where have you been all this time that's
the the first issue the second is that
even the way they're handling this is
eminently reasonable i'm reminded of the
segment we recently did where tucker
carlson
criticized a
cnn host named brian stelter because
brian stelter fired his nanny he fired
his nanny because she wouldn't get
vaccinated to be around his kid and when
you listen to brian stelter explain it
he says yeah you know we really like the
nanny
and so
we said let's wait six months she
doesn't want the vaccine but let's wait
six months because she'll see that it's
safe and she'll come to the decision on
her own that she's gonna get the vaccine
to protect our kid or kids i don't
remember how many and she still didn't
do it so it was really tough but we did
let her go because we want someone
vaccinated around our kid
eminently reasonable and here with the
military it's
we're giving you months notice that by
november 2nd you've got to be vaccinated
if you refuse we're going to give you
counseling if you refuse we're going to
give you education we will then just
give write it up and still not discharge
you it is endlessly endlessly reasonable
for a group that historically just
line up and get vaccinated that's it now
the other takeaway here
is that the vaccine requirements really
work
um the pentagon shows that about 90
percent of the active duty forces
vaccinated and 74 of the total force
including reserves and the national
guard that's significantly more than the
general population of course it's made
up of adults so we got to make sure
we're comparing apples to apples so
we're going to continue to see what
happens elsewhere so far just 27 people
and so anybody telling you this is
unpatriotic and weakening the military
it's 27 people from the air force army
deadline is december 15th
um there will be another deadline like
the final final final deadline is the
army national guard that's not until
june of 2022 so those are the latest uh
numbers as we now understand them
remember we were told we may lose tens
of thousands of service members here so
far it's 27. we were told we might lose
a third of nypd
it was what some type there was it 34
people or something along those lines
united airlines there's going to be no
flights there's going to be no nothing
almost everybody is vaccinated now at
united airlines so it's really a twofer
at the end of the day in the sense that
you improve the overall health of your
personnel you reduce the risk that your
personnel are going to contract covet
and be sick and be out etc
but we're also getting rid of some of
the wackiest people as we've said before
there's probably if you imagine a venn
diagram of police we don't want
because of reasons other than they don't
want the vaccine either use of force not
the types of people we want
and police that don't want the vaccine
there's probably a lot of overlap there
we're probably getting bat rid of a
bunch of those bad apples by saying if
you won't get vaccinated you got to go i
would suggest to you
that it's the exact same thing when it
comes to the military if you disagree
let me know
we have not spoken about oan for a while
oan is one america news or sometimes
it's o-a-n-n
one america news network oan is sort of
the crazy uncle to newsmax which is
already like the crazy uncle to fox news
fox news is hard right wing propaganda
news max is extreme right wing
propaganda and oan would sort of be like
something even more insane i don't even
know what it's crazier than newsmax with
even worse production value and anchors
who struggle even more obviously to read
the teleprompter i want to call your
attention to a segment that aired
yesterday on oan
this is a blend
of globalist one-world government
conspiracy theories
combined with straight-up lies about how
things work in the real world
the anti-vaccine absurdity
has reached a new level on oan and in
this clip we're going to hear from an
anchor named christina bob that's bob
with two b's
at the end b-o-b-b
she was visibly struggling to read the
conspiracies off of the teleprompter the
whole segment but the case she makes is
that globalists
globalish as uh alex jones would say
are getting ready to scrap the nuremberg
code in europe
in order to make covid vaccines
mandatory for all now there are maybe i
think one two
there's like six or seven layers of
dishonesty
and confusion in this segment let's look
at the video listen to the video you'll
notice that compared to this drivel
newsmax almost seems measured if you can
believe it let's take a look
covet is about control and manipulating
our physical bodies through the vaccine
which is one of the most humiliating and
inhumane ways to demoralize a person by
depriving them of control of their own
bodies and subjecting humans to medical
experiments it's for that reason that
the world created the nuremberg codes
after world war ii
we recognized that medical experiments
concentration camps mass murder and all
the other atrocities that occurred
during the war
were inhumane and should never be
tolerated again
yet the european union leadership is now
calling for throwing out the nuremberg
code ursula vanderlei the head of the
european union commission has argued in
favor of throwing out the nuremberg code
ignore it completely and allow countries
to force vaccinate anyone refusing to
participate in the medical experiment
the globalists are going crazy and
resorting to crazy methodologies that
most humans would not agree with like
ignoring the nuremberg code
why
because they are losing it is a last
resort to out themselves as the evil
inhumane tyrants that they are so
i mean listen let's just go line by line
right covet is about controlling other
people no it's not
covet is a pandemic and we're trying to
get out of it safe
the vaccines manipulate our physical
bodies this is along the lines of they
change your dna they don't that's not
true
the vaccines are inhumane
there is no scientific basis for that
assertion the vaccines are a medical
experiment no they aren't they're
approved by emergency use authorization
and the pfizer vaccine has full fda
approval and then we get into like the
really wacky stuff
the nuremberg codes were created to stop
medical experiments she says now that's
true
the nuremberg codes were created after
world war ii
and it does relate to human
experimentation it just has no relevance
to vaccines that have been approved at
all
the european union is not calling for
throwing out the nuremberg code and this
is like the big lie
uh ursula von der lion is the head of
the european commission
and she recently said at a press
conference the european union's member
states should encourage
and they should think about making
vaccines mandatory not you have to make
them mandatory
member states meaning countries like
belgium france etc they should think
about mandatory vaccination she didn't
mention the nuremberg code she said
nothing about scrapping the nuremberg
code she said nothing about allowing
medical experimentation vaccination has
nothing to do
with nuremberg code this has nothing to
do with globalists or globalism this is
not anything to do with the new world
order or one world government or
anything like it but this is exactly how
this stuff spreads think about the chain
ursula
van der lion
says
country should look at mandatory
vaccination
it is then reported on falsely as she's
saying get rid of the nuremberg code and
the next thing you know the eu wants to
re-legalize
nazi medical experiments it is how it
builds it's one layer of propaganda
built on another and another and another
have they no shame no they have no shame
but this is about something much much
worse and uh
i don't expect this to end anytime soon
their claim
is the left wants to keep us in the
pandemic forever to control people
understand that it is them
who in a way benefit from the pandemic
by being able to get clicks by spreading
this nonsense day after day after day so
don't fall for it
this is how it spreads and we're gonna
have more on this including uh this clip
on our instagram i hope you are
following us there at david pakman show
and you can also follow me on instagram
david.pacman we'll take a quick break
and we have plenty more coming right up
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to join joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
this has really been one of the most
remarkable weeks in this january 6th
investigation being carried out by the
house committee because not only did we
learn about the existence of all of
these different documents and by this
week i mean in the last you know seven
days in the last week not necessarily
this calendar week
the powerpoint outlining how to do the
coup which we talked about on monday but
also these text messages received by
mark meadows who increasingly seemed to
sort of be
an important nexus in donald trump's
state of mind at the time and and what
he was doing and this is going several
layers deeper and deeper
now there are increased calls for ivanka
trump's text messages to be obtained
ivanka trump of course the adult
daughter of donald trump who advised him
if you can imagine something more insane
during the trump administration even sat
in for trump's secretary of state at the
g8 or g20 i never remember which it is
the independent now reports that there
are calls issued for ivanka's texts from
january 6th to be released why well
because south carolina republican
senator lindsey graham revealed
ivanka was a
pass through to donald trump on that day
texts handed over so far from mark
meadows show that don jr was in touch
with mark meadows saying this looks
terrible we looked at the text yesterday
and the day before he's got to go out
there he's got to tell them to go home
etc etc
graham has said he wasn't texting with
mark meadows but says he spoke to ivanka
trump and asked her to send a message to
donald trump saying tell the people to
leave
now of course that that has been uh
revealed previously unknown that ivanka
was in the loop
now there are calls from a whole number
of people including democrats and some
republicans to see ivanka trump's text
messages as well so first of all should
we see those texts yes those have to be
obtained we'll see if the house
committee is able to do it number two
the family dynamics that all of this is
exposing
are pretty remarkable i mean don jr was
texting mark meadows to ask him to tell
his dad to call off the domestic
terrorists on january 6th
lindsay was able lindsey graham was able
to speak to ivanka
who i guess could get a hold of her dad
for whatever reason don jr couldn't but
ivanka could
and none of it's really surprising uh
whether the reasons are what we've known
about trump's relationships with his
sons as compared to his relationship
with ivanka which sometimes actually
seemed to go too far and start bordering
on a little bit creepy like when he said
uh if we weren't related i would be
dating ivanka something like that uh
maybe it has to do with just the
strained relationship with the boys it's
all bizarre
and then the last thing that i think
shouldn't be ignored
is whether it's possible that the text
don jr sent to mark meadows
might have been to create a cover in a
sense and uh
creating some kind of paper trail where
don jr could say no look i knew it was
bad i wasn't instigating or inciting at
all look at what i texted mark meadows
maybe knowing that it would make no
difference to his dad one way or the
other the other thing is lindsey graham
isn't always the most honest person
either so everything he says we should
uh take with a grain of salt at the end
of the day i wish there was a chance
that these people would actually face
real consequences i know yesterday in
our interview michael told michael cohen
told me they will
i just don't see it i just don't see it
the great thing is
whether these people are lying or
telling the truth
they do seem increasingly willing to
turn on each other to try to save
themselves and that's something that we
need to take advantage of on the left
we're going to talk about that a little
bit more on the last segment today also
lastly does anybody believe jared
kushner's fingerprints aren't all over
this thing i think they clearly are but
he's mostly uh stayed out of the
discussion so far that that may change
we'll have to wait and see
uh this you have to watch we wonder why
things happen
and then we see right-wing media
and then we realize why
fox news propagandist tucker carlson
went on a rant last night in which he
minimized what happened on january 6th
the day of the trump riots of course but
he also says in many ways the rioters
were correct they were correct in why
they were there
but the reasons he gives for why the
writers were correct are reasons none of
the writers actually knew about when
they rioted on january 6. i'm getting
ahead of myself and we're going to get
to that in a second this is so upside
down and backwards it really requires
almost like trapeze artist contortionism
to under to to even explain what tucker
is doing so let's see what tucker says
and then we will talk about it what was
january 6th
well there was destruction of property
which were totally opposed to
but what motivated why role is people
there
well for the most part a year later it's
very clear january 6th was essentially
what it appeared to be
thousands of ordinary american citizens
voters people who believe in our
democracy far more fervently than liz
cheney ever has
came to washington because they
sincerely believed democracy had been
thwarted
they believed the presidential election
was unfair and they have a right to
believe that and by the way in many ways
they were correct
the presidential election was unfair and
you don't have to get into anything
about voting machines to believe that
consider the facts that we know
as election day approach verizon
t-mobile and at t
shut down the trump's campaign's ability
to send text messages
and then google this has never even been
reported but it is widely known google
prevented the trump campaign from
raising money over gmail there's no
precedent for that the trump reelection
campaign lost millions in donation that
was the whole point of it
so the most powerful companies on planet
earth heavily regulated by the
government benefiting from government
contracts swung behind joe biden and
tried to stop donald trump the sitting
president in his tracks is that fair
okay so let's let's talk each piece of
that through
they were regular people who thought
democracy had been thwarted and since
they believed democracy had been
thwarted they were right to be there
understand that this isn't like
self-defense if you'd sincerely thought
your life was at risk you were able to
legally use any force necessary if even
if your life wasn't actually in danger
if you believed it
the fact that they s fell for conspiracy
theories about the election
and traveled to dc
and followed trump's directions and went
to the capitol and did all the stuff
that doesn't make them innocent because
they believed the election had been
stolen because this wouldn't even be the
way to handle it if that were true now
then tucker slips in a pretty pretty
slick move which is he says they have a
right to believe that that's a
linguistic trick no one's denying that
the rioters have a right to believe the
election was stolen they have a right to
believe uh joe biden died 10 years ago
and it's an electronic cyborg
replacement they have a right to believe
whatever they want they're not being
charged for what they believe believing
isn't a crime here the charges are for
the laws that they broke so that's a red
herring that tucker throws in but then
the meat of this segment
is tucker introducing totally different
reasoning for how they were correct and
what do you mean they were correct well
verizon t-mobile and at t shut down
trump's texting tucker says google
prevented trump from raising money over
gmail
these items were not a factor in the
rioters being there they weren't being
discussed at the time this is a
post-facto rationalization that tucker
has come up with but more importantly
are those claims even true and the
answer is no
um
unsolicited campaign texts to people who
haven't opted into them are legally
dubious it's a murky area because
sometimes campaigns will say well we
have voter registration data they've
registered to vote and so they are
people that are valid for us to target
whereas others say no no they haven't
opted into your communications you can't
text them and what happened the summer
before the election was that the trump
campaign
was clashing with a t verizon and
t-mobile third-party screening tools
were flagging trump's unsolicited texts
to people as spam trump's campaign was
arguing we can send these we are being
silenced
t-mobile at t and verizon are saying
unsolicited mass texts aren't allowed
and we have third-party tools in place
to detect that it was a murky legal area
and the idea that this was trump's
campaign being silenced is just
completely wrong
lastly tucker said google prevented
trump from raising money over gmail i
couldn't even find information on that
the closest thing i found is that at the
peak of the campaign some of you who are
on these lists might remember
the trump campaign was sending out
fundraising emails every 90 or 120
minutes eric jr donald trump i'm sorry
eric don jr trump we need your money we
need your money they appear to have
started getting caught in gmail spam
filters that's what happened
and because of their frequency they were
going to spam and being blocked on that
basis maybe there's more to that but i
have found no evidence at all
that gmail blocked trump from raising
money it seems they were sending such a
high rate of email that it started
triggering the spam filters on gmail so
not only is tucker wrong in that these
weren't the reasons the writers were
there tucker is wrong that these things
even took place lie
upon distortion upon deception upon lie
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow all right so i alluded
to this earlier you have to see the
level of chaos that the mark meadows
trump riot texts are causing in
right-wing media so let me reset the
story for you first and then we're gonna
just jump into something i i it's
genuinely delightful i don't know how
else to describe it earlier this week
republican congresswoman liz chaney
member of the house uh committee
investigating the january six riots read
a bunch of text messages
reportedly sent from fox news hosts and
donald trump jr to trump's then chief of
staff mark meadows
and despite going on air that day and
for weeks downplaying the riots it might
have been antifa it was blm it wasn't
real trump supporters i didn't actually
see any trump supporter being violent as
well as trump's own son and all of these
fox news hosts doing that on that day
they knew it was terrible and they knew
it was trump's problem and they were
trying to get trump on tv to make a
statement tell him to send everybody
home it exposes that everything they did
after the fact was just dishonest
cleanup and they knew exactly who was
there that day and that it was very bad
for donald donald trump period they knew
it they lied on tv to help trump no
surprise it's been confirmed
now
all of the different factions are
starting to go at each other because
they don't know how to manage this last
night sean hannity one of the people
implicated in this entire fiasco had a
segment
where he invited on geraldo rivera
um and this total right-wing nut dan
bongino who just defends trump always
and forever there's no situation where
bongino won't defend trump and geraldo
even though he you know was a trump
supporter is a friend of trump whatever
geraldo actually stands up sort of for
what's right and says to hannity listen
because hannity is continuing to
downplay the riots he says this was a
riot
it was inspired by trump supporters
period and hannity tries to interrupt
and her also says wait a second sean
think back to when you sent those texts
think back to your frame of mind when
you realized these are trumpists doing
this and this is violent and this is
terrible and you texted mark meadows
think back to that and bongino just
loses it on geraldo check this out was
the obvious difference between the riot
that happened on january 6th then the
500 odd that you correctly cite as
concerning and and and damaging to
america to our psyche to our our
physical well-being is that this was a
riot that was unleashed incited and
inspired by the president of the united
states which targeted we're not talking
about
american democracy the president didn't
say no you could target the
president said
no no stop the president said peacefully
patriotically march to the capitol
that's your opinion i don't even want to
go down that road that's not the
question tonight the question is this
corrupt committee the question is why
this riot and not 574 other rights the
question is is there any privacy in this
country anymore or do they get to
release thousands more of individual
private citizens texts
i beg you sean
to remember the
frame of mind you were in when you wrote
that text on january 6th and when laura
did and when brian did and when don jr
did remember the concern you had
remember the the frustration
that our our beloved 45th president yeah
because i wanted to see how to write can
he be doing this why doesn't he say
something why okay
but the point is he did you saw
unfolding before you you saw unfolding
before your very eyes an attack on
democracy
attack on the constitution
peacefully and then he did do it dan you
have less than a minute we're running
out of time haraldo we've been arguing
about this forever the backstabbing of
the president you're engaging in is
really disgusting and it's really vile
that you pretend to be this guy's
representative i resent that i supported
donald trump i supported donald trump
until
he refused to accept the will of the
american people you heard it nobody can
hear you
leave it there
so it's not backstabbing
it's telling the truth geraldo is saying
nothing controversial it was a trumpist
riot sean hannity knew it and texted
mark meadows at the time to try to stop
it and now he's playing a completely
different version of events on tv
day in and day out that's really it like
there's no more story and hannity pulls
in bongino to run interference and
they're starting to just go after each
other geraldo is no sage
right when geraldo is the voice of
reason you know things have gotten a
little bit wacky but this is what you
want to see this committee has already
done so much good
in all that it is exposed and all these
people are more than willing to go after
each other to save themselves remember
that
if republicans had just gone along with
the original committee
it is far less likely that all of this
same damaging information would have
come out why do i say that well the
original committee idea was
i believe these are the right numbers
five democrats five republicans
when they would send out subpoenas
the subpoenas would have to be signed
off on
not only by the democratic chair of the
committee but by the republican vice
chair of the committee
it was going to be
truly a committee that was not just
going to have carte blanche to go
fishing wherever they want republicans
uh and i'm not saying that that's what
it is now but republicans said we're not
going to participate we're protesting
this entire thing unless we're also
looking into you know the shooting of
steve scalise four years ago or whatever
else we don't want to participate so
nancy pelosi found some republicans
willing to be on it liz cheney's on it
adam kinzinger is on it don't remember
if there's any other republicans but at
least the two of them
and now you have a situation in which
they by virtue of republicans saying
we're basically opting out of this thing
and at least at the party level we don't
support it even if you found a couple of
our people to be on this committee
now they are actually doing really good
work and exposing incredible things
there was a powerpoint for the coup
all these people who for months have
been doing media saying it wasn't what
it was on that day knew exactly what it
was and we're texting mark meadows and
saying please help to stop it so it's
excellent that the committee is doing
this
it's exactly the type of insight
infighting and bedlam that we want to
see within the republican party bongino
have them all fighting that's exactly
what we want
they will turn on each other to protect
themselves that's abundantly clear if
you say
hey
the riot was inspired by trump which
obviously it was they accused their own
of backstabbing and geraldo
is or was a trumpet i mean he makes it
clear even in that segment the
difference is that hannity and bongino
will never admit that trump did anything
wrong geraldo will admit it and he'll
still say he is or was my friend and i
did or do support him it takes nearly 80
year old geraldo rivera to apparently
realize that what took place on january
6th was not just partisan bickering or a
rally it was something much darker and
much more sinister and hopefully this
level of chaos will continue
kyle rittenhouse
we knew that rittenhouse was going to be
lionized
and made into a hero after he was
acquitted in the killing of two people
and shooting of a third in kenosha
wisconsin and it is happening exactly as
predicted some of you republicans who
watch wrote to me and they said david
and and you said david you know um the
verdict was the right one but nobody's
gonna make a hero out of this kid
because ultimately what happened is a
tragedy and i said no no no no they're
going to make a hero out of this kid and
it's happening
first he got his media around he got to
meet donald trump
he was interviewed by tucker carlson he
was invited here he was invited there
everywhere at the end of the day
even if you believe that what kyle
rittenhouse did was legally justifiable
as self-defense which many people on the
left do and i said the way the laws are
written and based on the evidence not
guilty is the
quote correct verdict because it is
totally plausible that he feared for his
life
in a situation he never should have been
in into which he placed himself i i said
not guilty is what follows the way the
law is written
uh but what he did was still horrible
it's nothing to celebrate here it was a
failure of parenting it was a failure of
gun culture it was a failure of militia
culture vigilante culture all of these
horrible things that plagued the united
states there's nothing to celebrate here
but now
kyle rittenhouse is quite literally
being held up as a hero whose actions
should be celebrated and the latest
installment is this
um uh
speakership he he's going to be a
speaker
at this completely outrageous event held
by right-wing group turning point usa
called america fest 2021 in phoenix
arizona i will just miss it i've been in
arizona the last two weeks i leave
friday the event is saturday really a
shame huh and the question i have is
what is there for him to speak about
like how how to kill people and get away
with it
um
it's beyond sickening and again even if
you think he is legally not guilty as he
was found what is there to celebrate
here what is there to learn from him
other than you too could insert yourself
into a situation you have no business in
and get away with killing two people
like is that the lesson from kyle
rittenhouse's story there is nothing
here other than a cult of personality
and disgustingly they are celebrating it
and in so doing they are celebrating the
killings there's really no way around it
because there's no other substance
there's nothing there
and
the problem
there's a number of problems with this
but one of the questions that comes up
is
if we celebrate the fact that a 17 year
old did this what about a 16 year old
what about a 15 year old what about a 12
year old with good trigger discipline as
they love to say like where is the end
with this
um
maybe i'm wrong and he'll show up and
talk about how he's looking forward to a
career in nursing as we often heard
during the trial uh but somehow i don't
i don't think so and um i genuinely
don't understand what on earth
he would uh he would speak like what's
his open what is the body of his speech
and i can only imagine that he's getting
paid for this if you can imagine that
although maybe not the one thing that
makes me think maybe not is i was
invited onto charlie kirk's show a
little while ago travel didn't work out
um and they actually had the gall to say
we're a non-profit
so we don't pay anybody for appearances
and speaking and all that stuff i don't
know if they tell kyle rittenhouse the
same thing maybe he
he probably has a different uh status
within turning point usa than i do
but uh they actually
for for me and a few others i know they
said now we're we're a non-profit we're
a nonprofit so we we can't pay you to
appear so kyle rittenhouse being made
exactly out to be the hero that we
predicted they would how long does this
grift run i actually don't think it runs
that long i think it's like a couple
years
but uh maybe it's something that he can
use to keep the great gravy train coming
for a long period of time we have a
voicemail number that is 219 to davidp
uh you can call anytime here's a really
interesting question about some of the
coverage i've done of uh the things joe
rogan has said recently
and the caller is asking why aren't
other people on the left doing similar
coverage it's an interesting topic let's
listen
hey david uh first of all huge fan of
the show one thing i'd like to give you
a shout out for is you uh being able to
call out other people
like joe rogan such as more powerful
than yourself and one thing that's
really been bothering me is a lot of
people
on the left i'm not even going to call
them the so-called left but i noticed
they avoid criticizing people like joe
rogan and jimmy dore
and then when they are called out on it
they say well oh you know i'm personal
friends with them so you have to
understand that it's uncomfortable blah
blah blah
and it's like part of me sees where
they're coming from but look man i
worked in a grocery store first like
year and a half of cobit if you think i
didn't have to call out
friends who i've known way longer
than um
any of these people have done like jimmy
dore or joe rogan like i'm talking about
like 10 years like i've worked with
these people
like
that's far more uncomfortable than
calling out a work mate so like
people saying like oh you know you gotta
understand it's uncomfortable like dude
i'm the first one to say it's
uncomfortable i've had to do it
in way more uncomfortable circumstance
and like look this is a a once every 100
year pandemic this is important
um i hope those people still like me
but at the end of the day i don't care
you know
uh
yeah and and the caller goes on a bit i
can't really speak to why anybody else
does or doesn't do criticism of anything
in particular uh you know sometimes
people will write to me and they'll say
david why haven't you said anything
about this or that and it's like
sometimes i just don't have anything to
say about it um i will tell you that
there are people
who when i've done segments critical of
the things joe rogan has said about
whatever covid related vaccines
ivermectin whatever i will get messages
from other hosts saying
i think it was really great that you did
that actually and they don't say why
they are or aren't you know why they're
not doing it themselves in many cases
and i don't ask but everybody's got to
make whatever decision is right for them
you know joe rogan is a guy i met twice
and have exchanged some messages with
and i think that on a lot of things he
has interesting insights i think he's
gotten a lot of things just flat wrong
on kovid and uh to the extent that i
think that his audience is falling for
things that are wrong i'll do my best to
correct it in a respectful way and as
i've said before i have no idea whether
rogan's even aware of the fact that i've
done that coverage if he is and doesn't
like it and never wants to have me back
on that may be the case if he uh has no
idea that i've done it i would go and
talk to him about it in person i mean i
really for me this is not a personal
thing
i'm seeing what's being said
and who has audiences that are listening
and if i feel that it has to be
corrected i do it that's my view and
then you put aside the personal stuff
we have a great bonus show for you today
cornell has shut down its ithaca campus
after
major omicron signs have been found
while at the same time we are getting
better looking information about the
severity of omicron which uh
what we will talk about a joe biden is
set to surpass donald trump in first
year judicial nominees which is a big
deal this was one of trump's big
accomplishments judges and joe biden is
set to surpass trump for that first year
we will also talk about the house of
representatives passing a euger forced
labor bill or uyghur forced labor bill
depending on your preferred
pronunciation what is in it what is its
jurisdiction we'll talk about it on the
bonus show you can sign up at
joinpakman.com
excuse me also remember that on january
1st we will be doing a single day
membership special to kick off the new
year if you'd like to participate just
get on our mailing list at
davidpakman.com
we will see you on today's bonus show
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors disco delivers
affordable science-backed skin care
treatments to your home the disco
starter set helps guys fight oily skin
and razor burn and keeps your skin
hydrated i've had great results with it
you'll get 30 off at letsdisco.com
pacman the link is down below